Most modern malware use packing, and
there are many packing tools
we call packers available.
There are many,
many ways to obfuscate malware code.
Furthermore, there are hundreds of
thousands of malware samples released to
the internet every day by attackers and,
like I said, most of them are packed.
This means we cannot manually
analyze all the malware samples.
Instead, we need automatic approach to
unpack malware and analyze malware, and
such approach has to be universally
applicable to all the malware samples.
An approach that we can take,
is to combine static and
dynamic analysis to do
fine grain analysis.
In particular, with static analysis we
look at the packed malware code, and
we get a set of instructions
in the packed program.
And then, we run the malware, and
the dynamic analysis, we can
identify instructions that are not
in the statically identified
set of instructions.
Meaning that, these are new
instructions that we did not see in
the packed program.
These must be instructions that have
been unpacked just before execution.
In other words, by identifying
instructions that we can only see one
time, we have identified part of
the program that had been packed.
Once we identify the unpacked code,
we can then apply other anti-malware
techniques, including signature
scanning, to identify the malware logic.
For example, even though after packing,
each malware instance looks different,
the malware code,
meaning original instructions,
once unpacked remain the same.
Therefore, after unpacking, we can still
use a signature to identify the malware.
For example,
the instructions that have been packed
can be the logic that the malware
uses to do key logging, and
a signature base approach can
identify this part of the malware.